.
>> WITHOUT GOING INTO SPECIFICS
OF WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO, WE
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
SITTING DOWN.
>> THAT REBUKE COMES AS CHINA
HAS REPEATEDLY REFUSED TO
CONDEMN RUSSIA'S ATTACK ON
UKRAINE, GOING SO FAR AS TO
REFUSE TO CALL IT WHAT IT IS: A
WAR.
DAVID CULVER IS OUT FRONT
TONIGHT WITH THIS REPORT FROM
SHANGHAI.
>> BEIJING FIGHTING BACK AGAINST
THE U.S. WARNINGS NOT TO HELP
RUSSIA IN ITS INVASION OF
UKRAINE.
TODAY A FOREIGN MINISTRY
SPOKESPERSON WARNING THE UNITED
STATES NOT TO UNDERMINE CHINA'S
LEGITIMATE RIGHTS AND INTERESTS
WHEN DEALING WITH U.S.-RUSSIA
RELATIONS, ADDING CHINA AND
RUSSIA WILL CONTINUE TO CONDUCT
NORMAL TRADE COOPERATION.
BUT MIGHT THAT COOPERATION SOON
INCLUDE MILITARY SUPPORT?
>> BEIJING WOULD THINK OF THIS
AS A TIGHTROPE WALK, BUT I THINK
MOST OBSERVERS SEE BEIJING BEING
AN ACTIVE SUPPORT FOR MOSCOW.
>> Reporter: BEIJING AND THE
KREMLIN DENY THEY HAVE SOURCES
FOR AID.
THEY HAVE ASKED FOR DRONES AND
PREPACKAGED FOOD KITS, OR MREs.
IN ROME, CHINA'S TOP DIPLOMAT
TOLD U.S. ADVISER JAKE SULLIVAN
THAT CHINA WANTS PEACE AND COULD
SERVE AS A MEDIATOR.
THERE IS ALSO HUMANITARIAN AID
FOR UKRAINE.
CHINA IS ALREADY RUSSIA'S
BIGGEST TRADING PARTNER AND
LIKELY THE ONLY SUPERPOWER THAT
COULD HELP SLOW THE ECONOMIC
FREEFALL.
PUTIN AND XI ANNOUNCED A NEW OIL
AGREEMENT.
THEN THERE IS AGRICULTURE THE
SAME WEEK THAT THEY LAUNCHED
SEVERE SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA.
CHINESE STATE MEDIA SAID IN
2021, TRADE BETWEEN THE TWO
JUMPED $17 BILLION OVER THE
PREVIOUS YEAR AND INCLUDES
RUSSIAN SEED OIL, BARLEY AND
BEEF.
EVERY MINUTE COUNTS WHEN YOU'RE
LOSING CUSTOMERS AS QUICK AS
RUSSIA.
RUSSIA COULD LOOK TO SETTLE ITS
TRADE DEBTS WITH CHINA, USING
DHIN CURISTS RELIEF EFFORTS.
>> -- THE ECONOMIC RISKS MIGHT
DO HARM TO CHINA.
>> THE SINKING SHIP IS VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
CHINA HAS BACKED THE WRONG
HORSE.
>> Reporter: BUT WITH A STATED
MEANINGLESS AUTOMATIC ALLEGIANCE
TO FELLOW AUTOCRACY.
>> CHINA IS IN A PRETTY GOOD
SPOT.
THEY'RE ABLE TO KEEP THEIR
LUCRATIVE TRADE WITH THE WEST
AND SUPPOSEDLY GET EXPORTS FOR A
BARGAIN.
ANOTHER ROUND OF COVID LOCKDOWNS
HERE.
CRUSHING BUSINESSES.
YOU HA